some Democrats are preparing for a trump
impeachment inquiry since the mullah
hearings ended and now a majority of
House Democrats are saying that they
suppose such a measure is ready to
unfold this fall House Judiciary
Committee Jerry Nadler going even
further by laying out of potential
timetable watch this if we decide to
report
articles of impeachment we could get to
that in the late fall / late latter part
of the year I think that we will
probably get court decisions by the end
of October
or maybe shortly thereafter we'll get
we'll have hearings in September and
October with people we don't who are not
dependent on that witness it's not
dependent on the court proceedings so it
looks like Jerry niala has laid out a
timetable sometime this fall more than
120 Democrats I'm really surprised that
the numbers is is that that low right
now seriously given all the talk on a
presidential trail but jesse is there's
no question that this fall you're going
to see the House Democrats conduct an
impeachment inquiry against a president
I say who cares it goes nowhere in the
Senate I don't think it matters at all I
mean go ahead do it it's gonna hurt your
party it's gonna help the president I
mean there was no collusion I mean what
are you so worked up about you framed
Trump he caught you they triggered a
special counsel he beat it back and now
it just looks like the Special Counsel
investigation was to cover up the frame
job I mean there is no crime and
everybody can see that
and the mulher stunt failed so now
they're just flailing around trying to
make something else work and nothing has
worked so far so they're just gonna
impeach him cuz they don't like them
because they can't beat them well what
do you think John I think it's a bad
move because if I was a Democrat I would
say I would not do that because we all
know that a lot of moderate Democrats
voted for Trump throughout the the
Midwest and through there and they got
their jobs back and they're making more
money and their taxes are lower and
they're going we'd like to see that
continue but you guys are focused on
impeaching the scout and coming up with
reasons to do it I think it's going to
backfire arms Danny you think of whole
pig stomaching and Annie Donaldson come
forward and testify and lower the
temperature and give chairman Adler
the committee what they need that this
could go away well I mean me go away and
that it would never like impeachment
would never happen I think that I think
if they you know I have had I think
we've all had people whispering in our
ear that the evidence is coming the
evidence is coming okay well we are
about almost one year away from a
presidential election there's no
evidence so far and what's happening I
think one of the reasons these numbers
are going up House Republicans are
wanting to bring take back the house
they've got an uphill climb but one of
the things that they're doing is they're
taking those 31 districts where Trump
won the House District and then the
Democrat won it in 2018 Republicans are
trying to push those particular
Democrats into supporting impeachment so
that they can run against them and
hopefully get those seats back that's
their plan
and I'm think the Nancy Pelosi is trying
to protect those people from that but I
don't know if she'll be able to hold it
off well Gregg everything is on the
shoulders a barrel against his name is
Beryl Howell and he's the judge that
will decide whether or not some of the
grand jury testimony will be given to
the House Judiciary Committee again will
that stop efforts to impeach the
president you know what this is like me
writing a love poem and sending it to
Halle Berry nothing's gonna happen I'm
not it's going nowhere yes he could but
again I mean this is a political act
meant to circumvent the vote who that
doesn't reduce the temperature of the
country hardly
I mean it's smart to impeach him well my
problem is is that once we most people
think that if we impeach Donald Trump we
will remove him from office
unfortunately that will happen so I do
believe that the Judiciary Committee
should conduct an inquiry but the truth
is we need to find another way to get
rid of Donald Trump and that's called a
straight when you're left yeah that's I
think that's why you guys are scared
that's why you're going for the
impeachment cuz you don't think you can
beat them I'm not